mic Lombardi of the ringer joining us
here on the show what do you make of all
this
Mike well hello rich though I oru Ange
time in the NFL you know it's
interesting
Chris Ballard left the Chiefs and then
three months later we see their general
manager get fired and then Brendan Breen
leaves the Carolina Panthers and we see
Dave gentlemen get fired today and I
think what you're seeing here is a
reflection of somebody told the players
no on their contract I like Steve Smith
was was released because of their
calorie cap and gentlemen basically ran
the team with the idea that he could
develop some players while he left the
Angela Williams go and felt like Josh
Norman they could replace him on their
team for less money than it was going to
cost them and so when you do that you're
going to alienate some players and I
think the concern you have is the
general managers you just got to try to
be honest and upfront with people I
think you can't tell them look I'm going
to pay you and then not to him and that
causes some problems I think you have to
be fairly 4/4 right and talk to them and
you know Belichick told me this back in
1992 when he came in to Cleveland he
said look if you want the players to
like it you're in the wrong job and I
think what you're seeing here is the
reaction from the players about
Gettleman he did what he was supposed to
do with the cap not saying he was right
saying he did what he thought he had to
do well so why why did the Panthers and
as you mentioned the Chiefs as well
you've got two guys in Jordan John
Dorsey and Dave gentlemen now let go in
the summer months what right what is
happening difficult different situations
I think where you looked at John's
situation in Kansas City
I think Clark Hunt felt like there was a
lack of communication from the personnel
department to through the organization
you know John is a really good player
evaluator John Dorsey does a really good
job of evaluating talent but when you're
the general manager and I think teams do
this quite often as they hire college
scouting directors and they make them
general managers and then they want them
to stay in the office and handle some of
the stuff these guys are you want to be
on the road and John liked being on the
road like Ted Thompson Ted Thompson
likes being on the road he's a scout by
heart and you know that was great when I
started the league in 84 because you had
to be on the road because you had to
have 16 millimeter tape to watch the
players but today because of the video
because of the digital video that you
set your desk and watch all the tape and
I think there was a lack of
communication between the front office
and the Chiefs and I think they felt
like they needed a better communicator
and aligning their organization that's
why they made the move with John Dorsey
that doesn't mean John's not a good
scout that doesn't mean John's not a
great evaluator that means John's
administrative skills were not what they
wanted in Kansas City
that's for government I think he paid
the price for being the guy who said no
he said no to a lot of players he
alienated a lot of players and I think
if you look over the history of the
Jerry Richardson administration in
Carolina he has a relationship with the
players he's been a former player before
and I think that wears down on you and
if the owners not completely behind you
in the decisions this is what happens
Michael Lombardo of the ringer joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show what is
happening between Washington and Kirk
Cousins Michael well this is the best to
me this is the highlight of the summer
this might be as good as baby driver as
a movie you know just to watch this I
think what's happened is the Redskins
miss evaluated this from the beginning
okay they felt like in Bruce Allen their
general manager whatever you want to
call Bruce Allen he runs their team he
controls the money and I think what you
saw with Dave gentlemen is the person
that controls the money is ultimately in
charge of the team you can be you can be
titled general manager like Scott
McLuhan was but if you don't control the
money you don't run the team you know
it's the old Watergate thing rich follow
the money and you know who's in charge
Bruce controls the money Bruce
miscalculated the ability of Kirk
Cousins I think they still miscalculate
the ability of Kirk Cousins there was a
time period when Kyle Shanahan joined
join me within a brief little bit that I
was still in Cleveland and he wanted to
trade desperately for for Kirk Cousins
and Bruce was really being indifferent
about maybe making a trade and he wanted
the second-round pick at that time and
you know it was hard to trade a
second-round pick for a guy you hadn't
seen play in pro football but Bruce was
calculated this from the beginning he
thought he could convince priority
sports and mike mccarthy and mark barlow
stay in the NBA agent and rick smith
that he could he could kind of convince
him in taking a deal because part of who
Bruce is as a general manager is he was
a former agent so he thinks he can sell
he can sell or talk a cat off the top of
a fish truck so I think what happened
there is he must calculate it and then
his only out was since he continued to
miss Kay
it was to keep franchising them and so
now he's in a situation where the player
has played far better than he thought
but clearly not to the level that he's
being paid and he's put the agent in a
position where it's easy for them to say
you know what why should we do a deal
let's just walk it through rich let's
say he doesn't sign a long-term
extension of the number he wants he goes
out he buys a life insurance policy that
could protect him for future years won't
cost him that much money maybe cost him
say costume
you know half a million dollars he's got
plenty of money in the pocket he could
defects himself for future investments
that's all tax free money to have
happens to come through and then he sits
there and he puts the pressure back on
Washington and says you know what either
you franchise me again or I'm just going
to take a stroll out to the west coast
to my good friend Kyle Shanahan who
loves me and they'll pay me a market
deal for the next five years so this is
a situation that Bruce never saw through
or looked past and it's what it's it's
what I call the false duality it's when
you only think of a or B where Belichick
does so well as he said he'd to makes
every decision based on a B and then
he's able to figure out what C D E and F
are what Bruce did here is saw a or B
and now he's faced with a false duality
there's no longer a or B there's a lot
of C D E and F and G Mike Lombardi the
ringer here on the Rich Eisen show so
you don't think cousins is going to sign
that they're not going to come to a
long-term agreement unless I got to pay
the freight that he wants why should he
he has all the leverage which he has had
all the leverage since they put the
franchise tag on any one out and played
well leverage is what matters in sports
I mean look let's face it if you have
the leverage you can even get more deals
done for with players in September on
extensions than you can in March why
because in September players are worried
about injury they fear something they
don't have the leverage but when you get
to March they're no longer feel for of
an injury they're out there they want
the best deal and so you have to
calculate when you want to do it Bruce
thinks he has the leverage because he
sends these funny proposals to entitled
the Billy Kilmer proposal or the Sonny
Jurgensen proposal to Rick Smith and in
reality they're not going to listen to
him they've been around the block too
much he can't convince them to come
top of the fish truck so what's
happening between levy on bail and the
Steelers best you can tell Michael I
would just suspect it's a it's really
about how I what the number is I mean
the one thing about doing these
contracts rich when you're in this level
of a franchise player you're they're
easier contracts to do in terms of
average per year they're harder
contracts to do based on spread of the
money based on the guarantee dollars of
the money and you know that's usually
where lies the problem and you can agree
to a number because there's enough of a
market sample to say hey look here I am
again the problem with Kirk Cousins is
the market sample far exceeds Cousins
ability he's going to be paid above and
beyond a number that the Redskins had no
idea that they could ever want to pay
they had no idea they want to pay it so
they're negotiating against themselves I
think in lay beyond Bell's case they
know he's one of the top one or two
backs in the league they're working off
that number if he happens to they say
he's the best back in the league then
it's about how much more he can make
above and beyond then we get into the
difficult area how we're going to
guarantee the money how it's going to be
spread over the contract how much is the
first three years of the deal what fans
don't always understand is all these
deals are evaluated on three years
they're not valuated on when it comes
out hey here's the five year total
they're evaluated on what's in the three
years and how much of the guarantee is
in the first three years do you get 80%
guarantee did you get 75 did you get 65
those are the key numbers so what do you
think ends up happening with me I would
seems like they do it the I mean
Pittsburgh is always good about reciting
their players and they get to a point
like they did with Mike Wallace where if
they're not going to do a deal then
they're able to walk away so one thing
you know when you're dealing with
Pittsburgh is Pittsburgh will leave the
table
Pittsburgh's owner their culture is what
matters more than anything well when
your culture matters you're willing to
leave the table and find another back I
think that lay beyond knows this I think
they'll do a deal for a really above
market deal I hope so I mean cuz look I
mean Kirk Cousins is is a quarterback of
note and he has flashes of excellence
and we can we can go back and forth
about his value levy on bail there's no
argument there's no argument where he
stands certainly you know in in the
national last several years I know he
hasn't played all 16 games because
of things that have gone down off the
field I'm sure the Steelers are
reminding is representatives of that
over right now but there's no question
as they operate men's that's pretty easy
to do I mean first of all the signing
bonus language already protects you on
that so if you miss any games due to
suspension off of a signing bonus you're
going to get a refund on the signing
bonus it's what happened with Josh
Gordon that's why he was upside down
with his Browns contract he had been
suspended so much that he end up owing
the Browns money for missing games and
so there's already language in there
again this is about spread of money it's
about guarantee I think average per year
is the least problem they're going to
have in Pittsburgh Mike Lombardi of the
ring or joining me here and the Rich
Eisen show so what the hell's happening
with Ezekiel le best you can tell me
right now you know which is he can spin
Zeke has been an interesting offseason
character I think what you found is is
there's been some toys been in Vegas
quite a bit he's been Grogg has gotten
exposure for partying a little bit but
Gronk is a very he's the Dean Martin of
partying you know D Martin released to
pretend he drank all the time and never
Dre was apple juice in there and I think
rocks a little bit like Dean Martin
doesn't really do a lot but it looks
like she's having fun and I think what
you see with Z because he is having fun
and he's out there and I think the
season has gotten away from him and I
think that they're having a harder time
controlling his actions off the field
and I think this is going to be the one
area where you'll see that it could
become problematic for the Cowboys I
think Adam Schefter reported on Friday
that they're preparing for some sort of
suspension which is what I'm hearing I
wrote a column for the ringer and talked
about why I think the Cowboys are really
in jeopardy in the first five games of
the season because they're going to lose
David Ervine one of the early one of
other better players they're going to
lose they've lost him for four games
they could potentially lose Zeke Elliott
because of these off the field
mismanagement behavior and they're
having a hard time talking to the agent
to get control of the situation normally
when you're dealing with this situation
if you're using the agent using the
families and everybody to help you
Corral the young man in Elliot's case I
don't think he's listening to anybody
and I think this is getting going from
bad to worse fairly quickly so if you
said the cousins Redskins situation is
the baby driver of the NFL summer what
is the soundtrack for that song Michael
you got a like something from the
Springsteen Hoover I know about Cyril I
think it's all about miss cow
so I think it's a you don't know me I
think that's the title of the song you
don't know me and I don't think they
know they don't know Kirk Cousins and
they refuse to want to pay them you know
rich it happens all the time you know
you you you you sign a player as a free
agent coming out of college you don't
want to believe he's a great player
because how could he get through the
draft instead of just evaluating what
your eyes tell you and so you end up
having these conditions built up in your
mind that aren't accurate and you should
just evaluate the player because you
know what sometimes we miss cousins is a
good player he'll be a good player if he
goes somewhere else that's what he does
Rhambo can't wait to get you back from
the Jersey Shore from your own private
beach can't wait to have you back here
no I'm not I'm not chris Christie I'll
amongst the people here I'm not laying
back here like a hundred all right Lamba
thanks a lot you got at Mike at M
Lombardi NFL the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches